[Musik]
hi herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid ja
heute ist tatsächlich ein richtig
intensiver erster Arbeitstag für den
neuen Verteidigungsminister Boris
Pistorius heute morgen wurde er schon
vom Bundespräsidenten ernannt und dann
später im Bundestag vereidigt ja und
dann steht jetzt heute Vormittag gleich
schon der erste wichtige amttermin an
nämlich ein Treffen mit dem US außen äh
US-Verteidigungsminister Leute Austin
der ist tatsächlich auch schon in Berlin
und wird gemeinsam mit Pistorius und
Verteidigungsministerium den am Freitag
geplanten Gipfel der Ukraine Verbündeten
auf dem US-Luftwaffenstützpunkt
Rammstein vorbereiten ja da sind wir
noch mal Bilder von der Vereidigung und
die Frage die jetzt zu diesem Treffen so
medial im Raum steht ist wird
Deutschland den Kampfpanzer Leopard
liefern verschiedene europäische Partner
wie Polen oder Großbritannien hatten in
den letzten Tagen da noch mal richtig
Druck auf Schol gemacht und gestern gab
es dann die Meldung scholzer bereit
allerdings unter einer Bedingung dass
auch die USA Kampfpanzer liefern würden
ja deswegen gucken wir jetzt mit
Spannung auf dieses Treffen zwischen Ost
sind und Pistorius und wir wollen gleich
gemeinsam hier mit euch live auf die
Statements bei dem Treffen schauen und
wir wollen natürlich darüber diskutieren
und sprechen zum einen mit euch ich
möchte aber auch sprechen mit meinem
Kollegen Dominik schepka der ist
zdf-hauptstadt Korrespondent und mit
Militärexperte und General aD Wolfgang
Richter und wie immer brauche ich dazu
natürlich eure fragen Kommentare und
Anregung stellt die einfach gerne hier
direkt in Youtube Chat oder schickt sie
uns per Mail an ZDF heute - live at
zdf.de würde aber sagen jetzt schalten
wir erstmal rüber nach Berlin zu Dominik
Chapka hallo Dominik hallo Viktoria grüß
Dich
ja Dominik was ist denn die Erwartung an
dieses Treffen heute ich habe ja schon
gesagt seit gestern ließ man das Scholz
wohl bereit wäre Kampfpanzer zu liefern
aber nur wenn die USA Kampfpanzer
liefern würden erwartest du da jetzt
heute eine Antwort also so ganz
hundertprozentig mit dieser ganz
knallharten Voraussetzungen können was
noch nicht bestätigen was wir hören ist
das in der tatbewegung in der ganzen
Frage drin ist und das wichtig ist ist
das ist das allererste Treffen von
Pistorius es ist gleich Weltpolitik er
trifft da gleich den chefchef eigentlich
den US-Verteidigungsminister
zur Pressekonferenz sorry Dominik alles
gut erstens
aber wir haben sehr viele Themen
besprochen und diese Möglichkeit haben
wir heute
als ersten
zu dürfen es gibt naturgemäß in diesen
Zeiten besonders wichtige
Gesprächsinhalte
zuallererst natürlich die Frage der
andauernden Unterstützung der Szene in
diesem furchtbaren Angriff Krieg
Angriffskrieg Russlands
es geht um Abstimmung von nato-themen
natürlich es geht um das Vorgehen im
Indopazifik es geht um die erste
deutsche nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
und bei all diesen Themen das ist
offenkundig sind die USA wie auch schon
in der Vergangenheit unser wichtigster
Verbündeter
Putins entsetzlicher Angriffskrieg auf
die Ukraine
hat der NATO die Chance gegeben sich als
das zu erweisen was sie ist nämlich ein
tragendes ein stabiles Bündnis dass ich
reaktions- und handlungsfähig gezeigt
hat und weiter zeigen wird dafür bin ich
sehr dankbar und insbesondere deshalb
weil dieses Fundament auf dem die NATO
steht und auf dem das Bündnis steht
eines ist dass sich ein gemeinsamen
Werten orientiert an einer gemeinsamen
Strategie
gemeinsamen Vorgehen und gemeinsamer
Verantwortung
und wie so oft in der Geschichte aber
auch gerade jetzt in diesen Zeiten
stehen die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
und die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
dabei Schulter an Schulter im Vorgehen
aber auch in den konkreten Fragen seinen
ist die Schützenpanzer die Patriot
Flughafen
deutsche Systeme bewähren sich in der
Ukraine
panzerwitzen Gepard oder hochmodernes
Flugabwehrsystem ihres TSS
und gemeinsam das kann ich sagen werden
wir auch in Zukunft mit unseren Partnern
gemeinsam die Ukraine in ihrem Kampf für
die Freiheit und die territariale
Unabhängigkeit und Souveränität
unterstützen ich freue mich auf eine
exzellente Zusammenarbeit mit der
sekretary dir Lloyd schon morgen werden
wir uns in Ramstein wiedersehen dann mit
dir als Gastgeber
guten Morgen
vielen Dank für die Begrüßung heute ich
weiß dass sich der erste Gast bin seit
sie das Amt übernommen haben aber das
ist schließlich auch erst vor einer
Stunde der Fall gewesen ist überrascht
er sie nicht
vielen Dank also für die Begrüßung und
Glückwunsch zu ihrem neuen Amt ich freue
mich auf die künftige Zusammenarbeit
und das freut mich erneut hier in
Deutschland zu sein
ich erinnere mich an viele Momente hier
in Deutschland in meiner ersten Mission
Deutschland ist weiterhin eine der
wichtigsten Verbündeten der USA
an dieser Stelle möchte ich daran
erinnern dass gestern schrecklicherweise
ein Helikopter abgestürztes in der
Ukraine und über 12 Menschen sind dabei
ums angekommen auch der ukrainische
Innenminister Denis monastirski
diese Zeiten waren
aufwühlend in Europa und alles ist
zurückzuführen auf den schrecklichen
Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine
Deutschland war über diese Zeit ein
wichtiger Partner für die USA und ein
wichtiger Verteidiger unserer Werte mit
unserer Bündnisse wir werden also
weiterhin die Ukraine unterstützen
während sie sich während gegen die
russische Aggression und bei der
Verteidigung ihres Gebiets
danke der deutschen Regierung für die
Unterstützung für die Ukraine für die
Unterstützung auch bei der Ausbildung
und Lieferung von
Waffen an die Ukraine
ich danke Ihnen auch für die
Präsenz und für schnelle Operationen und
für schnelle Transporte von militärgern
und
Soldaten an die Ostflanke treffen uns
morgen in Ramstein gemeinsam mit unseren
Partnern
für die das Treffen der Ukraine
Kontaktgruppe wir sind weiterhin
entschlossen die Ukraine langfristig zu
unterstützen dass sie sich selbst
verteidigen kann
im heutigen Treffen werden wir über
viele Themen sprechen die morgen
behandelt werden gemeinsam mit unseren
Partnern es wird auch um weitere
grundlegende Themen für die NATO und die
bilaterale Verteidigung Zusammenarbeit
gehen
Herr Minister vielen Dank für die manche
Begrüßung ich freue mich auf unsere
Gespräche und auf eine enge
Zusammenarbeit ich freue mich wenn euch
hier zu sein herzlichen Dank
ja so weit die Statements von pistory
und und Austin das Thema der Kampfpanzer
wurde nur am Rande angeschnitten gerade
Austin blickt auch noch mal zurück auf
bisherige Besucher in Deutschland es
wird vor allem eine zukünftige gute
Zusammenarbeit betont und darüber
sprechen wir jetzt noch mal mit Dominik
den ich vorhin leider kurz abkanzeln
musste aber jetzt ist er wieder bei uns
Dominik was sagst du zu diesem
Statements ich fand schon auffällig dass
Boris Pistorius zur aller erst mal von
den Schützenpanzern gesprochen hat also
das sind die mörderpanzer die
Deutschland ja schon vor zwei Wochen
angekündigt hat eben auch in Absprache
mit den USA er selbst hat das Wort
Kampfpanzer nicht in den Mund genommen
es gibt aber Experten die sagen
Kampfpanzer und Schützenpanzer
funktionieren eigentlich ganz gut
zusammen die Kampfpanzer und die quasi
gerade vorweg fahren und erstmal
schießen und dann hinterher die
Schützenpanzer Menschen transportieren
um diese Linie die
Hilfslinie weiter nach vorne zu treiben
funktioniert vielleicht nur beides
zusammen aber dann hat pistorisch etwas
sehr Wichtiges gesagt sondern wir werden
gemeinsam mit unseren Partnern die
Ukraine weiter unterstützen und auch
Austin sagt langfristige Unterstützung
der Ukraine das sind schon so zwischen
den Zeilen Hinweise darauf dass in der
Frage der Kampfpanzer ebenfalls Bewegung
drin ist
ja wenn wir quasi jetzt die Antwort auf
diese Frage die medial eigentlich seit
einigen Tagen Wochen alle beschäftigt
nicht bekommen was glaubst Du wann
können wir Sie denn erwarten ob
Deutschland im Verbund mit den USA
liefert ist das was wir heute am Ende
des Tages erfahren können ist das was
morgen auf in der Rammstein Konferenz
besprochen wird was sagst du eher nein
unsere Informationen hier im ZDF
Hauptstadtstudio sind dass wir eher noch
ein paar Tage warten müssen vielleicht
muss Olaf Scholz muss die
Bundesregierung auch noch ein ganz klein
bisschen Zeit gewinnen um die Panzer die
Deutschland hat fit zu kriegen doch mal
nachzuzählen und auch um diplomatisch
noch mal ein paar Weichen zu stellen was
wir hören ist das heute und morgen das
in weitesten Sinne vorbereitet wird auch
diplomatisch vorbereitet wird das ist
keine Alleingänge geben soll aber dann
ist Olaf Scholz ja am Sonntag in Paris
deutsch-französischen Ministerrat wird
dort an der Seite von Immanuel macron
stehen dem französischen Präsidenten und
das hat eigentlich viel Kritik daran
gegeben dass Frankreich das letzte Mal
zwei Wochen bei den Schützenpanzern ein
bisschen vorgeprescht sei Deutschland
angeblich so die Kritik ein bisschen
hinterhergehängt sei und wenn man dann
in Paris steht und an der Seite von
macron steht wäre das eigentlich eine
ganz gute Gelegenheit um da etwas zu
Leopard Panzern zu sagen also ich würde
eher auf den Sonntag tippen
hundertprozentig wissen was natürlich
nicht
okay also hier die Einschätzung das
nicht heute oder morgen diese
Entscheidung vielleicht wird sie
getroffen aber sie wird vielleicht auch
am Sonntag eher von Kanzler Scholz
verkündet ja Dominik danke dir für deine
Einschätzung soweit vielen Dank nach
Berlin
sehr gerne
mit diesen ganzen Panzern da kann man
schon mal durcheinander kommen es gibt
Schützenpanzer es gibt Kampfpanzer dann
haben die alle noch verschiedene Namen
gepaart Leopard ich dachte das ist
deswegen sinnvoll dass wir uns noch mal
angucken was da jetzt was ist und wie
was das Dominik gerade auch schon
angedeutet wie die im Zusammenspiel
funktioniert und das ganze hat Dominik
Lessmeister uns hier noch mal
zusammengefasst
der Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 ist stark
gepanzert er wiegt über 60 Tonnen und
hat 1500 PS er hat eine leistungsfähige
120 mm Glattrohrkanone ihre Aufgabe
andere Panzer und Fahrzeuge beschießen
oder zerstören oder der Infanterie durch
Beschuss von Häusern oder Stellungen
helfen dabei werden die Kampfpanzer von
Panzergrenadieren mit Schützenpanzern
unterstützt Schützenpanzer wie der
Marder sind gepanzerte
Transportfahrzeuge für Infanterie
Soldaten sie sind beweglich nicht so
schwer wie Kampfpanzer und haben auch
eine leichtere Kanone bei Marder eine 20
mm Bordkanone ihre Aufgabe Soldaten
schnell und geschützt im Gelände
absetzen zur Besatzung können Sie sechs
weitere Soldaten und Soldaten aufnehmen
feindliche Infanterie und deren
gepanzerte Kampffahrzeuge bekämpfen
gemeinsam mit den Kampfpanzern halten
Sie die Bewegung und Stoßkraft der
Panzertruppen aufrecht im Verbund
entfalten Schützenpanzer Marder und
Kampfpanzer Leopard ihre größte
Wirksamkeit darum ist die Unterstützung
der Ukraine mit Kampfpanzern wie dem
Leopard der nächste logische Schritt
ja so viel zu den Panzern und den
Hintergründen darüber und über diese
ausstehende Entscheidung wollen wir
jetzt sprechen und zwar mit
Militärexperte und General ade Wolfgang
Richter hallo Herr Richter schön dass
Sie bei uns sind
hallo Frau Reichelt oberster Weg darf
ich vielleicht mal kurz ergänzen
entschuldigung das ist natürlich absolut
korrekt wenn ihr
wenn ihr fragen habt an Herrn Richter
oder eure Meinung zum Thema teilen wollt
dann schreibt uns die gerne hier in den
Chat bei Youtube oder schickt uns eine
mail ans ZDF heute- live at zdf.de Herr
Richter sie haben ja eben auch die
Statements verfolgt wie schätzen sie
denn dieses Statements an
zunächst einmal waren
Statements geprägt von der gemeinsam von
dem gemeinsamen Willen der Unterstützung
der Ukraine auf der langfristigen
weiteren Unterstützung der Ukraine das
lässt natürlich offen was man im
Einzelnen dann braucht das wird davon
abhängig wie man die Ressourcen bei der
Seiten der Ukraine und der Russen
Vergleich denn es muss ja darum gehen am
Ende die ukrainische Armee zu befähigen
also ihre Souveränität zu verteidigen
und ihre Unabhängigkeit zu wahren
gleichzeitig sind aber beide Staaten
durchaus sich bewusst dass es auch
eskalationsrisiken gibt und deswegen
wird das alles sehr sorgfältig abgewogen
was man eben liefern muss und wo man
nicht sich abstützen muss für
Deutschland kommt ist vor allem darauf
an keine Alleingänge zu machen das ist
ein sehr bekannt seine alte Linie vom
Bundeskanzler Scholz und das passt auch
in die Gesamtlinie deutscher
Sicherheitspolitik in den letzten Jahren
anders bedeutet auch dass man natürlich
eine solche Lieferung abhängig machen
wird einmal von dem von dem Bedarf in
der Ukraine zum anderen aber auch von
dem mitgehen anderer Verbündete und da
haben wir ja schon aus Großbritannien
und aus Polen und Finnland einiges
Statements gehört die in diese Richtung
gehen aber das muss jetzt noch einmal
genau überprüft werden jedenfalls können
wir festhalten es gibt keinen Tabu
Kampfanzug zu liefern sondern es gibt
ein Tabu keine nationalen alle
eingegeben durchzuführen und dann muss
man das ganze in dem strategischen
Kontext einordnen es geht um die
Wirksamkeit zunächst mal auf den Boden
der Tatsachen also in einem Gefecht
verbundener Waffen dann aber auch wenn
ich sagte strategischer Kontext meine
ich die gesamte Frontbreite und dann
sieht das eben doch ein bisschen anders
aus wenn man also
Kompanie Stärken von Kampfpanzern über
die man jetzt redet vergleicht mit den
Ressourcen die man eigentlich braucht
und letztlich muss Deutschland natürlich
prüfen was es verfügbar was kann man
etwas aus dem aktiven bundeswehrbestand
nehmen eher nicht wenn wir stehen in
einem Konkurrenzverhältnis wir haben
lauter Verpflichtung zu erfüllen und
zwar sehr schnell und dann bleiben also
industriebestände die allerdings auch
noch etwas aufgemotzt werden müssen
verbessert werden müssen so dass man sie
liefern kann hier kommt dann der
Zeitfaktor ins Spiel also alles das wird
zu überprüfen sein natürlich auch
Logistik und Ausbildung und bevor dieser
Dinge nicht verstehen wird man auch
keine schnelle Entscheidung treffen aber
ich glaube generell ist die
Weichenstellung geht schon in die
Richtung den der russischen Seite zu
signalisieren wir werden die Ukraine
weiter unterstützen was immer es braucht
um sicherzustellen dass die Ukraine
diesen Krieg nicht verlieren
sie haben ja auch gerade davon
gesprochen wie wichtig es ist da keine
schnell national Alleingänge vorzunehmen
jetzt wirkt es ja aber in den letzten
Wochen oder Monaten so als ob eigentlich
im europäischen Verbund Deutschland so
ein bisschen den Alleingang macht mit
diesem zögern oder
also den Eindruck habe ich eigentlich
bisher nicht denn es ist ja alles im
Verbund besprochen worden was die
einzelnen Staaten liefern dafür gibt es
ja auch diese Abstimmung in der
Rammstein Gruppe aber es gibt darüber
hinaus eine Abstimmung in einem
kleineren Kreis also den engsten
Verbündeten USA Deutschland Frankreich
Großbritannien und hier wird schon genau
besprochen was man liefern sollte und
was nicht an die Zögerlichkeit die man
Bundeskanzler Scholz oft unterstellt
gibt es natürlich aus guten Gründe denn
selbstverständlich muss der
Bundeskanzler darauf aufpassen dass die
eskalationsrisiken in Form gehalten
werden und dass wir die Situation nicht
noch weiter verschlimmern und insgesamt
muss man ja auf die europäische
Sicherheit achten auf die Sicherheit der
NATO als ganze ist da steht doch stolz
überhaupt nicht alleine denn bisher hat
ja niemanden
westliche Kampfpanzer durchaus
rechtliche Jahr auch die Amerikaner
waren bisher sehr zögerlich bei
bestimmten Waffensystem ich denke hier
an die Langstrecken oder längere
Reichweite der heimatraketen die man den
nicht geliefert hat eben weil man auch
Sorgen hatte vor der Eskalation und
selbst bei denen kürzere Reichweite also
der Unterschied besteht bei etwa 380 km
bei der längeren Reichweite und 70 bis
80 km bei der kürzeren Reichweite und
selbst dabei hat sich beiden versprechen
lassen von den Ukrainern was sie nicht
über die russischen Grenzen schießen
also damit will ich nur sagen die
Bedenken sind überall da man muss das
natürlich ähm man kann solche Risiken
von der Schwächen sie müssen gut
überlegt werden und dann kommt man zu
einer schlussfolgung und dann muss man
sich natürlich auch überlegen und davor
war nicht ein bisschen dass man den
Kampfpanzer jetzt nicht als wunderbar
für sie der den Krieg verändert er kann
örtlich natürlich erhebliche Gewinne für
die Kampfkraft der Ukraine schon
bedeuten im Verhältnis zu dem älteren
Hotel der T20 Modell
aber wie das ja auch Anklang in ihre
Einspielung der Kampfpanzer führt den
Krieg nicht alleine die duell-situation
ist die Ausnahme in einem Krieg sondern
es gibt ein gefechtverbunde Waffen und
im Gefecht wird wunderbar Waffen spielen
Kampfpanzer Schützenpanzer mit
infantrieb und vor allem auch die
Artillerie die Aufklärung vorweg die
Pioniere alle die spielen eine Rolle und
derjenige der das versteht das Gefecht
verbundene waffengesagen besser zu
führen da wird sich dann auch
durchsetzen aber wenn wir vom Gefecht
verwunderwaffen reden dann müssen wir
hier von
breiten reden die also Bataillons Größen
des Brigade maximal divisionsgrößen
umfassen dann war der Union kann sechs
bis acht Kilometer von breite halten das
hängt immer sehr von der Lage ab und
dann muss man das Vergleichen mit der
Frontbreite von 1.200 Kilometern die man
insgesamt in der Ukraine hat und dann
relativiert sich das Bild ein bisschen
wenn wir über Kompanie Stärken von
Kampfbahn zu reden aber gleichwohl das
Signal ist klar das politische Signal
Deutschland und die USA und die anderen
Verbündeten werden die Ukraine weiter
unterstützen und wenn es eben nötig ist
dann eben auch mit der Lieferung von
Kampfpanzern aber das muss man dann
langfristig sehen
denn selbstverständlich müssen Verluste
ausgeglichen werden die die Ukraine
ja zum Verhalten von Olaf Scholz haben
wir hier auch eine Stimme aus dem Chat
da sagt Dirk Forstner auf Youtube
erstmal zu einem historius es ist schade
dass Herr Pistorius wie auch unsere
Bundesregierung keine Einarbeitungszeit
hatten ich finde das Verhalten von Olaf
Scholz bezüglich der Panzer sehr
besonnen und vielleicht daran auch eine
Anschlussfrage die Sie vielleicht schon
so ein bisschen angerissen haben in
ihrer Antwort die NATO-Staaten sind sich
in ihrem Verbund ja gegenseitig zum
Beistand verpflichtet da ist es ja
wahrscheinlich tatsächlich auch
erforderlich das Waffenlieferung sehr
genau abgestimmt werden oder
ja absolut man muss diese
Waffenlieferung selbstverständlich
abstimmen denn ich sage ja schon es gibt
ja auch gemeinsame datenverpflichtungen
wir haben uns nicht nur in unserer
Strategie sondern auch in der sagten
Aufstellung der der Streitkräfte
Beiträge ja verpflichtet bestimmte Dinge
zu tun dazu gehört für Deutschland
insbesondere die Stärkung der Ostflanke
einmal durch unsere Präsenz in Litauen
und die Verstärkung dieser Präsenz durch
eine Brigade die dann vorgesehen ist
notfalls also die die Kampfgruppen
größer auf eine Brigade Größe zu
erweitern zweitens durch eine schnelle
Angreifer Reserve und hier geht es um
die sogenannte Speerspitze die digitalf
die Deutschland dieses Jahr führt und
auch diese Verpflichtung muss der
verständlich eingehalten werden in
kürzester Zeit müssen Kräfte in der Lage
sein die Auslage zu verstärken
und insgesamt und das ist ja das große
Thema das den verteilungsminister jetzt
beschäftigen wird geht es ja darum die
bundeswehrum zu gestalten um zu
strukturieren auf die Bedürfnisse der
Landes- und bündnisverteidigung und
nicht mehr auf nur sich zu konzentrieren
auf Einsätze im Ausland die er leichter
Einsätze waren stabilisierungseinsätze
mit leichten Kräften das ist jetzt
anders und das heißt wir müssen in
kurzer Zeit mit voll ausgestatteten
schweren Verbänden in der Lage sein
hochintensive Gefechte zu führen so wie
das in der Ukraine derzeit sichtbar ist
und diese Aufgabe wird uns langfristig
beschäftigen und deswegen stehen alle
Unterstützungsleistung für die Ukraine
eben auch in einem Konkurrenzverhältnis
zu den nötigen
materialausstattungen die die Bundeswehr
ja selber braucht und deswegen wird man
immer genau abwägen können wir das aus
dem aktiven bestanden nehmen oder ich
glaube eher nicht oder müssen wir auch
industriebestände zurückgreifen und die
entsprechenden
ja und zu diesen Beständen oder zum
Zustand dieses Materials haben wir eine
Frage auf Youtube von Atomic Tom der
fragt warum werden die vor einigen
Monaten erwähnten Leopard 1 Panzer nicht
mehr in Erwägung gezogen reicht die
Panzerung nicht oder ist der Zustand
einfach nicht gut genug
nun die Leopard 21 sind wir schon lange
nicht mehr im Bestand der Bundeswehr ist
ausgemuster die stehen teilweise noch in
Lagen oder in der Industrie
manchmal ist es so dass solche
Kampfpanzer dann vorgesehen werden
schlichtweg zu Verschrottung
andererseits könnten sie wieder
aufpoliert werden für den Export so war
das in der Vergangenheit ich glaube dass
die älteren Leopard 1 Panzer dir nun
Ende der 60er Jahre konzipiert worden
waren
jetzt für diesen Kampf nicht die erste
Wahl sein werden sondern dass es eher
darum geht Leopard 2 Panzer vielleicht
nicht dass die letzten Modelle die
modernsten Modelle aber doch A4 A5
eventuell so vorzubereiten dass sie in
den Einsatz gehen können das wird aber
eine ganze Weile dauern ich brauche ja
schon von Konkurrenzverhältnisse
Bundeswehr und den
Bedürfnissen der Bundeswehr selbst das
heißt die Industrie wird wohl beauftragt
werden müssen diese Dinge vorzubereiten
etwas zu steigern in ihrem Kampfwert und
erst dann wird man über konkrete
Lieferungen reden und dann geht es
natürlich auch um die Zahl die Frage ist
also wie viel stehen dann überhaupt zur
Verfügung
ja so viel zu den Leopard 1 Panzern
lassen Sie uns mal einen Blick auf die
Panzer aus den USA liefern da geht es ja
immer wieder um die Abrams Panzer die
die USA aber eigentlich nicht liefern
will woran liegt das
ja zunächst einmal ist das ein sehr
schwerer Panzer ist durchaus in vielen
Dingen vergleichbar mit dem Leopard 2
Panzer in seinem moderneren Versionen
auf dort gibt es ja unterschiedliche
Personen
er hat vielleicht zwei Dinge die man
berücksichtigen muss erstens dadurch
dass er eben sehr schwer ist ein also
deutlich über den 60ern liegt hat er
dann Probleme über bestimmte Brücken in
Europa zu fahren das ist eine das andere
ist er fährt mit Kerosin das ist nicht
das was man als massentreibstoff in
Europa sofort verfügbar hat natürlich
kann man das abzweigen Logistik steht
sowieso in der Ukraine vor einer
immensen Herausforderung einiges das ja
diese Vielzahl unterschiedlicher
Waffensysteme Ersatzteile Munitionsarten
und jetzt dann eben auch
betriebsstoffarten das ist für ein
Logistik eigentlich ein Albtraum aber es
muss bewältigt werden es geht nicht
anders zu viele Nationen liefern
sozusagen verschiedene Modelle und das
immer nur in kleinen Mengen und das ist
die Herausforderung an den Logistiker
ins ist dann glaube ich dass man
sicherlich Argumente finden kann warum
der Abrams jetzt nicht die erste Wahl
gewesen wäre aber überreichend
überschreitend gegenüber all diesen
technischen Argumenten sind die
politischen es ist selbstverständlich
klar dass Deutschland nicht allein immer
Alleingang etwas tut deswegen wird es
immer aus deutscher Sicht wichtig sein
dass der hauptverbünde die die USA mit
an Bord sind es hilft ja nichts wenn
beispielsweise eine Flotte von Leopard
Panzern dort erscheint in der Ukraine
die dann nach wie vor ja letztlich ein
deutsches System darstellen und dieses
deutsche System wird ja auch durch
Deutschland genehmigt werden müssen
selbst wenn es andere Armeen im Einsatz
oder im Bestand haben deswegen kommt es
darauf an dass zumindest bitten
Franzosen und Amerikaner mit anzeigen
ja zwischendurch hat unser Bild mal ein
bisschen gehackt Herr Richter aber ich
habe sie auf jeden Fall Wunder ein paar
verstanden
lassen Sie uns mal ein bisschen auf
Russland gucken jetzt gab es ja die
Meldung dass laut britischem
Geheimdienst Russland den kleinen
Einsatz den oder den Einsatz einer
kleinen Zahl dieses neuen TV 14
Kampfpanzers in der Ukraine plant
soll wohl aber so sein dass es bei bei
dieser Entwicklung Probleme gab und der
Einsatz eigentlich unsicher sei ähm
deswegen denkt man dass es hier vor
allem um Propaganda geht können Sie uns
was zum Einsatz dieser neuen T14
Kampfpanzer in der Ukraine sagen
ja zunächst mal fällt natürlich auf dass
bisher die Russen diesen neuen Avatar
Panzer gar nicht eingesetzt haben
dass er bei Paraden zu sehen war dass
das sicherlich die modernste Ausführung
russischer Panzer ist steht außer Frage
aber wie das bei ganz hochmodernen
Systemen der Fall eben ist es gibt dann
immer Kinderkrankheiten die erst im nach
lange Erprobung ausgemerkt werden können
wir haben ja selber ein Beispiel gehabt
kürzlich nämlich unseren neuen Puma
Schützenpanzer das dauert immer eine
Weile jeden moderner solche Systeme sind
umso schwieriger wird es sein Sie in
kurzer Zeit einsatzbereit und
zuverlässig einsatzbereit zu machen
das das Problem denke ich haben alle
modernen Armeen und das haben natürlich
auch die Russen sie sollen sich
wahrscheinlich auch diese modernste
Technik einzusetzen weil sie befürchten
müssen dass irgendwo dieser Kampf dran
sind ukrainische und damit auf den
westliche Hand fällt und damit also ihre
technischen
geheimhaltungsbedürftigen
Leistungsangaben dann in die westliche
Welt sondern das mag ein Kriterium sein
aber ich glaube auch dort dürfen wir
nicht davon ausgehen dass ein einzelner
kampfpanzertyp den Krieg wendet der
Kampfpanzer wie ich vorhin schon mal
versucht habe für verdeutlichen ist die
nur nur im Ausnahmefall in einer
duell-situation im Einsatz und in der
Regel im Gefecht verbundener Waffen und
es kommt dann darauf an die
Möglichkeiten aller Waffensysteme so
aufeinander zu stimmen dass der
bestmögliche Effekt dabei erzielt wird
nehmen Sie nur ein Beispiel die
Kampfentfernung eines sehr modernen
Leoparden kann zwischen 4 und 5 km sein
weil guter Sicht aber die gute Sicht ist
natürlich im Gefecht nicht immer da
vorhanden es gibt durchschnittliches
Gelände es kann hügelig sein ist vor
allen Dingen im bewaldeten oder Geländer
oder stadtkampf entfallen natürlich alle
diese Reichweiten Vorteile und dann
kommt es darauf an wir verschiedenen
wirken Gattungen Waffen und so
einzusetzen dass sie aufeinander
abgestimmt dann den bestmöglichen Effekt
erreichen das heißt man muss dann diese
wunderbar Unglaublichkeit ein bisschen
relativieren so ist das nicht und dann
reden wir immer noch über das Gefecht
verbunden was Waffen das heißt über die
Taktik wir reden noch nicht über die
Strategie wir reden nicht über das
gesamt den Gesamtaufwand von Kräften und
dann müsste man genau auf die Ressourcen
aller Seiten gucken und sich dann ein
Bild machen wer kann denn eigentlich was
noch in diesen Kampf hineinwerfen und da
scheinen die Ressourcen bei den Russen
dann doch noch umfangreich zu sein und
auch in der Ukraine die ja eigentlich an
der panzerstärke Armee von Beginn an war
wird es so sein dass sie immer weniger
in der Lage ist ihre Verluste selbst
ersetzen und dass diese Last des
Ersatzes dann immer mehr auf den besten
fällt was ja auch in der Vergangenheit
schon war der Fall war der neue
Bundesminister historius hat ja einiges
System erwähnt neben dem schützen kann
sondern auch die Patsche Systeme die
also die Raketen
Abwehrsysteme auch ihre
stls Entschuldigung und auch natürlich
den mehrfach Raketenwerfer den
Deutschland aber auch die USA geliefert
ja ich würde gerne noch mal kurz bei
Russland bleiben es gab nämlich vorhin
eine Meldung der Nachrichtenagentur
Reuters das ist aus dem Kreml ein Signal
gab das ein Angriff im Krim Gebiet mit
US-Waffen als neue Eskalation des
Konflikts gewertet werden würde von
russischer Seite sehen sie da gerade die
Gefahr der Eskalation und das fragt auch
ein User Karl Henderson auf Facebook
sagt nämlich das wird alles eskalieren
ich sehe keinerlei D Eskalation wie
schätzen Sie das ein
also zunächst einmal ist ein Punkt
natürlich schon zu unterstreichen die
Frage was wirkt eskalatorisch wird sich
wahrscheinlich weniger an einem
Waffensystem festmachen lassen als an
der Frage der Kriegsziele und dann
kommen die Waffensysteme ins Spiel weil
nämlich die Frage dann sich erstellt ist
eine eine Menge von solchen Waffensystem
in der Lage die kriegszielsetzung zu
verändern und zwar den Kriegszielen
haben wir ja schon ganz unterschiedliche
Auffassung gehört wir haben von den
Russen und den Ukrainern Ende März eine
ja fast schon Kompromisslösung
verhandelt gesehen oder vorverhandelt
gesehen die etwa sagte man will den
Status den politischen Status der Kremer
15 Jahre verschieben man soll zwischen
den Präsidenten einen Sonderstatus für
den was
verhandeln das hört sich so ein bisschen
nach links 3 an und man verzichtet als
Ukraine von ukrainischen Seite her auf
den NATO-Beitritt und einige
die
Sicherheitsgarantien für die Ukraine
diese an sich vernünftig anmutender
Erklärung ist dann im Mai vom Tisch
genommen worden und die
verhandlungsfenster sind ja auch
weitgehend zugeschlagen worden vor allen
Dingen durch die russischen Annexionen
neuer Gebiete das heißt solange es diese
Maximalposition gibt solange ist
natürlich eine Verhandlung dann auch
schwer vorstellbar dann muss ja die
Souveränität und Integrität und die
Unabhängigkeit der Ukraine war aber die
Kriegsziele können natürlich sehr
unterschiedlich sein sprechen wir über
die Linie vom 24 februar oder sprechen
wir über die wiederum der Krimi die
Krimis mittlerweile gilt als russische
Staatsgebiet und hat natürlich wenn man
an einen solchen Angriff denkt ein
anderen Charakter was eskalulatorische
Risiken betrifft als ein zurückgegangen
russischer Kräfte etwa im Gebiets da
heraus hier Sache und casan insofern ist
die ist diese Frage durchaus mit zu
berücksichtigen und ich gehe davon aus
dass die Rammstein Gruppe und
insbesondere jetzt die
deutsch-amerikanische Konsultation und
auch später am Sonntag die
deutsch-französische diese Risiken
durchaus mitbewertet und das ist
eigentlich nicht das Ziel sein kann die
ukrainische Armee so zu befähigen dass
er die Russen und über alle Grenzen
treibt das glaube ich ist aber auch gar
nicht realistisch und so so vermute ich
so ist die ukrainische Armee gar nicht
aufgestellt dass da bin ich eher
skeptisch es kommt jetzt darauf an die
ukrainische Animation zu unterstützen
dass sie den Krieg nicht verliert dass
sie durchhalten kann dass sie die
Unabhängigkeit war hat der Ukraine und
dann eine Verhandlungsposition erkämpft
die dann dazu führt dass auch Russland
von Maximalposition zurückweichen muss
ja und wir haben noch mal eine Russland
betreffende Frage aus der Community von
Sven Odenthal auf Facebook der fragt
weiß man denn wie die Produktion von
Waffen in Russland funktioniert Putin
hat ja die Waffenindustrie angemahnt
schneller zu produzieren können Sie das
für uns einschätzen
ja es gibt zwei Dinge die hier zu
berücksichtigen sind das eine sind die
nationalen Ressourcen die russland hat
und die sind erheblich wenn sie mal in
die jährliche Ausgabe der militäre
Balance Londoner Institut für
strategische Studien schauen dann stellt
man fest dass Russland zu Kriegsbeginn
etwa 9000 Kampfpanzer und viele andere
tausend kampferzeuge in Lagern hat
natürlich sind die nicht in besten
Zustand es sind auch die neuesten
Modelle aber sie können repariert werden
jedenfalls teilweise und wenn sie dann
zu 100 oder 1000 dann ins Gefecht
geworfen werden dann zählt eben auch die
Masse ich habe ja vorhin schon etwas
Gefecht verbundene Waffen geredet und
ich über duell-situation und diese Masse
kann eingesetzt werden das heißt wir
müssen verfügen noch über Ressourcen das
zweite was du möchtest sind die
Sanktionen des Westens die dazu geführt
haben das ist für Russland weitaus
schwerer geworden ist Hightech Geräte zu
bauen Chips zu bekommen etc das muss da
muss man aber dazu sagen dass sich diese
Dinge nur langfristig auswirken werden
und was vor allen Dingen die Sanktion
möglich sind wir haben ja festgestellt
dass der Westen den globalen Süden nicht
überzeugen konnte an den Sanktionen
mitzumachen das heißt wir haben kein
geschlossenes Sanktionsregime und
insofern werden wird Russland noch in
der Lage sein auch weiter zu produzieren
wahrscheinlich im Moment zum Beispiel
bei den marshmallowkörpern auch ganz
deutlich der Fall zu sein und ich
vermute auch bei der Produktion von
Kampfpanzer ja das heißt die Antwort
hier muss sein die ressourcenlage der
Russen ist hoch
sie dort sollte nicht unterschätzt
werden andererseits wenn man auf
personelle Dinge geschaut wird natürlich
der russische versuche immer mehr
Reserven zu mobilisieren auch bei der
russischen Bevölkerung dann mehr und
mehr zu Unmut führen denn es kommen ja
immer mehr nicht mehr Verletzte und
verwundete zurück sondern eben auch
Worte in sehr hoher Anzahl und ich
glaube nicht dass Russland sich das
endlos leisten kann auch wenn Putin Herr
der Medien ist und vieles erklären kann
aber das wirkt irgendwann natürlich auch
zu einem Ende kommt auf der anderen
Seite haben wir ähnliche Probleme in der
Ukraine nicht was die Moral betrifft da
sind die Ukraine weitaus überlegen aber
wenn man auf die Demografie schaut dann
ist natürlich auch die ukrainische
reserverlage nicht unendlich also sie
haben bereits ungefähr eine Million
Frauen und Männer im Einsatz und man
merkt schon das weitere reservenbildung
dann eben auf Dauer schwierig werden ich
hoffe so schlimm dass sie als klingt
dass die Auswirkung der Gefechte die wir
jetzt zu erwarten haben gerade gegen
Ende des Winters dazu führen dass
irgendwo doch die einzig greift dass
dieser Krieg so nicht weitergeführt
werden kann das niemand hoffen soll und
vor allem die Moskau nicht hoffen soll
dass die Ukraine Mangel Ressourcen
zusammenbricht und ich glaube das ist
jetzt die Aufgabe auch der
randsteingruppe das deutlich zu machen
ja lassen Sie uns zum Schluss noch mal
den Blick von Russland
mehr auf das europäische
sicherheitsnetzwerfen da habe ich noch
zwei Fragen aus der Community für Sie
und zwar fragt iosha Walling auf Youtube
kommen die Panzerlieferungen überhaupt
noch rechtzeitig und wird auf Dauer
nicht Manpower diesen Krieg entscheiden
ja also manpower ist natürlich eine ganz
wichtige Sache ich habe vorhin schon mal
über die mal gesprochen die Ukraine
waren in der Lage kürzester Zeit
ungeheuer viele Reserven unterwaffen zu
bringen und
in die Streitkräfte einzugehen oder in
die Unterstützungskräfte für die
Streitkräfte man muss davon ausgehen
dass sie mittlerweile eine Million
Soldaten und Soldaten unter Waffen haben
bei den großen ist das noch nicht der
Fall sie haben natürlich aufgestockt
seit Januar gilt auch die weitere
Aufstockung um 137
000 weitere Soldaten die sie jetzt
gewinnen wollen für die Streitkräfte das
heißt sie werden dann bei etwa 1,2
Millionen Mann Gesamtstärke davon haben
sie aber nur es geht ja hier in erster
Linie um die heereskräfte da haben sie
nur ein Teil eingesetzt bisher also in
der Ukraine am Anfang waren sie sogar
personell unterlegen und jetzt versuchen
Sie das Bett zu machen durch
entsprechende Mobilisierung trotzdem
sollte man die ukrainische Stärke auch
was panz dürfte und artilleriekräfte
betrifft nicht unterschätzen die
Ukrainer waren zu Beginn des Krieges am
24 februar die zweitstärkste gepanzerte
Armee Europas mit etwa 1.100
Kampfpanzern waren sie fast viermal so
stark wie aktivstärke der Bundeswehr
Vergleich zu machen
das heißt die kämpfen nicht mehr mit
Soldaten und gelben Bussen das ist eine
übertriebene Vorstellung allerdings
haben sie hohe Verluste hinnehmen müssen
und diese Verluste sind zunächst in
sogenannten Ringtausch ausgeglichen
worden eben fast zum Teil wir müssen
davon ausgehen dass über 250 Kampfpanzer
ja von östlichen Verbündeten an die
Ukraine geliefert worden sind um diese
Verluste Weg zu machen das war das war
Mittel der Wahl ja das ging okay 72
Kanzler die also auch in den polnischen
tschechischen slowakischen oder
slowenischen Kräften vorhanden waren
dieser Ring Tausch der dann ersetzt
werden sollte Verbündeten durch
westliche Systeme kommt aber allmählich
und ihr Ende ist auch da sind die
Ressourcen nicht endlos das heißt es
liegt eigentlich auf der Hand dass man
dann eben westliche Ressourcen dort
direkt an in die Ukraine leiten muss
trotz allem ist kann man man kann sich
nicht vorstellen dass dieser Krieg der
ein gepanzer der Krieg ist ein
mechanisierter Krieg der mit einem hohen
Aufwand an Artillerie geführt wird der
mit einem hohen Aufwand vor allem auf
der russischen Seite an Raketen und
Luftangriffen geführt wird dass dieser
Krieg jetzt nur über Personal
entschieden wird auch wenn die Moral
natürlich eine ganz wichtige Rolle
spielt aber die Moral ist dann
irgendwann auch abhängig davon dass man
Erfolg auf dem Gefechtsfeld hat und auch
Verluste je höher sie werden drücken
natürlich auf dem Rad das sollte man
jetzt nicht übersehen das heißt das wird
nicht nur auf Menschen ankommen
natürlich tragen die das Gefecht das
völlig klar
aber es kommt eben auch auf die
Ressourcen an sonst kann man eigentlich
nicht führen
vielen Dank Herr Richter dass sie meine
Fragen und die Fragen aus der Community
beantwortet haben ich danke Ihnen sehr
für diese Einschätzung
gerne das hat mich gefreut alles Gute
ja also in diesen Statements gab es
jetzt noch keine Entscheidung
hinsichtlich kampfpanzerlieferungen aus
Europa in die Ukraine jetzt ist ja aber
morgen das Treffen in Ramstein ob sich
da was entscheidet oder vielleicht erst
später ihr werdet auf jeden Fall hier
erfahren vielen Dank für eure Fragen und
Kommentare und Anmerkung wir sehen uns
wieder wenn ihr mögt
[Musik]